[Musique]
la réunion était durement impactée par
la crise sanitaire liée à la pandémie de
coronavirus pour sortir de la crise le
département met en place un plan de
relance économique et social de 70
millions d'euros à court terme et 500
millions d'euros à moyen terme le plan
départemental
le but c'est quoi c'est de soutenir les
activités de soutien aux entreprises
pour que le chômage recule parce que
nous nous faisons un travail au maximum
de nos concitoyens et dans ce plan de
relance
eh bien vous avez aussi bien des mesures
sociales sanitaires comme la lutte
contre la dengue
vous avez aussi des mesures sociales
pour accompagner l'enfant sans
difficulté la réhabilitation des
logements anciens
je veux doubler le programme de
réhabilitation des logements anciens est
bien sûr aussi bas la partie agricole
avec une transition écologique
environnementale on veut planter un
million d'arbres
le département veut planter un million
d'arbres sur tout le territoire et parce
que c'est d'environnement ça pour une
qualité de vie dans nos quartiers et
pour cela je travaille avec les
professionnels les mairies l'état pour
réussir ce plan de relance l'agriculture
une des compétences du département
bénéficiera de plus de 40 millions
d'euros
bouffée d'oxygène pour les agriculteurs
donc ce sont 42 millions d'euros un peu
plus 42 millions d'euros qui vont être
injectés dans l'est dans l'agriculture
réunionnaise donc pour favoriser entre
autres la production et la vente directe
les circuits courts également les lieux
de transformation pour permettre aux
agriculteurs de capter toute la plus
value de leur production éviter des
gaspillages alimentaire également aller
vers une transition écologique donc ce
qui est demandé de la part des
consommateurs mais également de la part
des agriculteurs se sont quasiment 10
millions qui vont être fléché vers la
transition écologique donc aujourd'hui
la chambre d'agriculture par rapport à
ce plan de relance va s'attacher
également accompagner les collectivités
les mairies et autres pour qu'elle
puisse correspondre à la loi et galim
parce qu'il faudra intégrer 53 cents de
production locale dans les repas de
collectivités donc il faut que les
agriculteurs s'y prépare à intégrer ce
réseau de production et de
transformation pour répondre aux
au marché des collectivités une relance
économique et sociale qui passe
également par un gros faux l'est en
direction des petites et moyennes
entreprises qui seront notamment
sollicité dans le cadre du dispositif
d'amélioration de l'habitat dans les
crédits seront de 100 millions d'euros
alors concrètement pour nous ça pour
nous les entreprises dont qui avons eu
des difficultés donc déjà avant le coc
vide et principalement énormément nos
cadres locaux vides puisque les
chantiers sont ralenties ça nous apporte
une énorme bouffée une bouffée d'air aux
concerts qu'on puisse redémarrer nous
est un chantier d'autant plus que à
priori il y a déjà un budget qui a remis
en personne ce sont des chantiers qui
devraient démarrer rapidement
donc ça nous permettra à nous de
retrouver une certaine trésorerie
puisque ce que l'on craint c'est que
aujourd'hui il y a peu de chantiers qui
redémarre donc ce que l'on craint c'est
qu'on aime beaucoup d'entreprises qui
die mois à venir mais quelques sous la
porte
avec ce plan départemental de relance
économique et social la collectivité se
donne pour ambition d'être au plus près
des personnes fragiles et vulnérables
[Musique]